plus d essentielle - de super fou et si
le coït 10,9 remettait en cause notre
façon de consommer électroménager hi
tech vêtements en tout genre tout est
prétexte à dépenser ce phénomène de
surconsommation ne date pas d'hier
années 60 des trente glorieuses la
france devient société de consommation à
l'heure des grandes surfaces du
renouvellement incessant des gammes du
choix infini l'achat sans besoin
préalable est guidé par les ficelles du
marketing des gens 1965
ce modèle est dénoncée par georges perec
dans son livre les choses
la publicité des étalages des vitrines
une certaine manière nous rendent fous
nous saoulent toutes ces choses de son
lac pour entretenir une espèce de
frénésie de vertige hypnose en même
temps la consommation est une arme de
relance économique
celle que brandissait par exemple
georges pompidou en 1970 lors d'une
conférence de presse
je demande aux ménagères française je le
redis c'est le moment pour vous
d'acheter les machines à laver et
l'épanouissement personnel dans tout ça
l'électroménager la voiture la
télévision tout cet équipement est
brandie comme émancipateur tout le monde
s'équipent dans une société qui avance
mais ce modèle a ses limites c'est ce
qu'explique françois de closets en 1974
dans son ouvrage le bonheur en plus je
crois que de poursuivre le bonheur à
travers l'augmentation du confort et les
miens matériel c'est une voie il lui
soir c'est une voix illusoire et qui
nous conduit maintenant à des crises de
plus en plus graves nous avons vu les
premières îles vers l'arrivée
beaucoup d'autres la surconsommation et
son impact sur la société sont
critiquées depuis des années 60
à l'encontre de ces phénomènes une
résistance s'organise les achats de
seconde main les objets électroniques
reconditionnés et la consommation locale
prennent plus de place dans notre
quotidien
[Musique]